cette année encore lionel jospin part en
vacances sur l'île de ré où chacun
s'efforce de respecter sa tranquillité
trois semaines de repos avant une
rentrée qui pourrait être mouvementée
avec un éventuel remaniement ministériel
dans l'île impossible de savoir où ils
résident seule concession faite aux
médias
la traditionnelle photo sur la plage un
rituel auquel ont assisté laurent hakim
et philippe châtelain c'est le jeu de
piste de l'été mais où se cache
lionel jospin la villa et le quartier
qu'il occupait l'an passé ont retrouvé
leur anonymat le premier ministre
aurait-il boudé l'île de ré enquête de
voisinage
non je ne l'avais pas résume j'ai vu sa
photo dans le journal we are irlande en
fait ionel jospin c'est trouver un autre
refuge dans un autre port et le
traditionnel cache-cache organisé par
ses collaborateurs prend fin sur une
plage à l'heure de l'apéritif
la balade à vélo de l'année dernière a
laissé place à la balade sur le sable
entre le flux de la mer et le reflux des
photographes petites confidences sur le
programme estival
plus porté vers la mer et nice
lecture repos amis vélo fait plaisir des
temps et puis le premier ministre dit
qu'il a apporté ses devoirs de vacances
quinquennat unedic corse budget mais ne
lui parlez pas de remède en un an j'ai
le dos et maniement de marrakech trois
semaines de vacances studieuses lionel
jospin a promis de travailler plus tôt
que l'année dernière pour ne pas
culpabiliser il est vrai que sa rentrée
politique s'annonce chargé